1 divided by 1 is 1 1 divided by 0.1
means how many times is the decimal 0.1
contained within the number 1 the answer
is 10 times we can move the decimal
point over 1 again and have 1 divided by
0.01 the answer to that is 100 our
answer it's 10 times bigger every time
our denominator gets 10 times smaller
1 divided by 0.001 is 1000 so how small
can we go well 1 divided by zero point
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
one you can check on the calculator if
you like but it's 1 million and we could
keep going smaller and smaller with our
answer getting bigger and bigger
so we'll 1 over 0 e as large as infinity
it certainly looks that way
if we draw a graph the smaller our
number on the bottom of the fraction the
bigger the fraction seems to get
let's try it again but starting
somewhere else 1 divided by negative 1
is negative 1 1 divided by negative zero
point 1 is negative 10 1 divided by
negative 0.01 is negative 100 this time
when we move the decimal point over 1 we
are getting 10 times closer to zero and
our answer is getting 10 times smaller
one divided by negative 0.001 is
negative a thousand and one divided by
negative zero point zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero 1 is negative 1
billion so now 1 divided by zero looks
like it might be minus infinity as our
number on the bottom gets bigger our
fraction shoots down to huge negative
numbers this shows us what the behavior
looks like as we approach one over zero
from both sides but at exactly zero the
graph is going in two different
directions there is no answer to 1 over
0 1 over 0 is not positive or negative
infinity 1 over 0 is undefined
[Music]